hello and welcome to another exciting
episode of into the impossible featuring
myself brian keating and david chalmers
one of the foremost philosophers of our
time exploring the existential question
of whether or not we live in the matrix
david claims we do i push back
with requisite respect and admiration on
this claim and together we delve into
the essence of what existence is
can you get existence from pure
information what we talked about john
archibald wheeler's claim of it from bit
we talked about stephen wolfram and his
controversial ideas of underlying all of
physics through computation and cellular
automata what are the limits of
computation does computation require a
substrate either be it silicon or qubits
in that form or maybe a mind and maybe
an ultimate mind a creator if you will
we got into the aspects of the
simulation hypothesis that dovetail
identically with the notion of a creator
of a god we talked about why dave
himself does not worship or find god
worthy of worship even if god
even if she as he calls the master
simulator is uh is responsible for
creating the existence that we perceive
as reality
so this book reality plus is a
phenomenal book i listened to it i uh i
read it and i hope that you will too and
david is one of the foremost thinkers of
our time and i think he's come up with
something analogous to the drake
equation as we get into in this episode
that is pertinent to the probability of
finding out that we are simulated not
just that the uh aspects of simulation
are applicable to things like the
weather the stock market and all of
physics but actually that we are and he
came up with a version that i call the
chalmers equation in homage to the drake
equation we talk about the drake
equation talk about aliens and ufos and
all sorts of other cool things but
predominantly we talked about the notion
of reality and whether or not we could
distinguish ourselves from being in a
simulation
and i also asked dave my patented
thrilling three final questions you're
gonna have to subscribe to my mailing
list at brianketing.com to get notified
of that particular segment of the
episode so please subscribe on youtube
and please subscribe uh an audio
and uh and you will get those
existential questions and you don't want
to miss it from perhaps the foremost
philosopher of our time
david chalmers of new york university a
proud australian living down over now
in the northern hemisphere
and we had a thrilling conversation
almost an hour and a half in length so
sit back relax and enjoy this trip into
the matrix where it is claimed that we
are living as we speak right now and i
hope that you will enjoy this tour of
the matrix with yours truly brian
keating
associate director of the arthur c clark
center for human imagination uc san
diego
and lao let us go deep into the matrix
let's go any sufficiently advanced
technology
is indistinguishable from magic
open the pod bay doors welcome everybody
to a very very special very real episode
of the into the impossible podcast i am
your fearful host
professor brian keating of the arthur c
clarke center for human imagination
talking with a renowned intellect and
this is a rear a real treat uh when i
found out that his new book was coming
out i just had to get him and it is none
other than professor david chalmers who
first formulated the problem of the hard
problem of consciousness which we're
gonna get to in a paper facing up to the
problem of consciousness and way back in
1995 expanded upon it in his uh
wonderful book the conscious mind 96 his
works are provocative influential and
and uh some of the greatest luminaries
of all time including past guest stephen
pinker have called it uh so praiseworthy
and his claim and renown know no bounds
um and so first i want to welcome you
today dave how are you doing today all
the way in new york
thanks brian yeah great uh great to be
here it's kind of kind of rainy out here
but uh
i hope it's hope it's sunnier where you
are
yeah la jolla that's a fair game you
know i usually say you know the hardest
job in the world is being a san diego
sportscaster because we've never won a
championship in any sport but the
easiest job is being san diego is a
meteorologist because
72 in sunny 71 and a half in some you
know it's it's uh it makes up for uh its
lack of variance by its uh consistency
of beauty so yes it is quite lovely but
i am a native new yorker i'm a born and
bred in new york so sometimes the accent
will come out um and dave as i told you
right before we started my audience
loves it when i play the game
which we call judging books by their
covers and titles and subtitles so this
book has a butterfly very provocative
and beautiful butterfly which is kind of
the only character that makes its way
through a dream sequences throughout the
book the title is reality plus the
subtitles virtual worlds and the
problems of philosophy
dave explained to us what is the title
uh the meaning of the title and that
mischievous butterfly doing on there
sure should i be holding it up yeah
please very good yeah
there's the butterfly
yeah so um the book the title is uh is
reality plus actually
i started i had a working title for a
long time that was
reality
2.0 because this is about you know the
book is in large part about virtual and
artificial realities these could be the
uh
the uh
the second
class of realities first reality
physical reality but then we start
creating our own artificial realities
that's reality 2.0 another idea is it
could turn out that we ourselves might
be in a simulated artificial reality so
that our reality is reality 2.0 now the
only trouble is there's a fatal flaw
with this title which has probably
occurred to all of your listeners
already which is you know
reality 2.0 suggests to people
aol
1990s
you've got mail up yeah
it's it's so retro that it sounds like
it's a step to step backwards rather
than a step forwards was it yeah even
our colleague max tegmark went to life
3.0 to avoid this problem
reality 4.0 maybe not but
someone had the great idea of yeah well
reality plus
because although putting a plus
uh on the uh on the end of a title maybe
becoming a ubiquitous cliche too at
least in uh at least in streaming
services you know disney plus hulu apple
tv plus paramount plus and so on at
least it's a 2020s cliche and not a
and not a 1990s cliche and it kind of
suggests this idea of
there's more to reality than you think
there's physical reality there's virtual
reality there's
simulated realities and yeah if in the
future somebody comes up with a reality
streaming service
where you're able to choose between the
virtual realities that you want to live
in then reality plus might be a uh
might be an appropriate name for it so
in the end i thought okay gotta go with
reality plus gotta go with the plus sign
and that gives a a hint at the
enhancement that we're going to be uh
experiencing in the maybe augmentation
and supplementation but maybe even
full-scale replacement of our notions of
reality and i've had on as i said don
hoffman
believes reality does not exist and it's
sort of a
an avatarish scenario a desktop scenario
uh which is which is provocative and you
refer to him towards the end of the book
we'll maybe get a chance to get into
that uh i neglected to mention that you
are the co-director of nyu's center for
mind and brian consciousness so oh no
brain conscious
you know my mom named me you know brian
so that people would make that mistake
and it happens about two times a day um
and you were elected a fellow of both
the american academy of arts and
sciences but in your native land down
under of australia you were elected the
australian academy of humanities as well
and i want to start by
because i can't resist it's like if if
we were to hear
go to a concert by your countrymen ac dc
and they don't play you shook me all
night long there's just you know you're
going to leave unsatisfied i have to
take it from the master i want you to
define the hard problem of consciousness
yeah so the hard problem of
consciousness is the problem of
explaining how physical processes in the
brain
give rise to subjective experience to
the subjective experience of the mind
and the world so for me the core of
consciousness that word means many
things to many people
but the core of consciousness is
subjective experience of
perceiving of feeling
of thinking
of acting it's anything that feels like
something from the inside
and the easy problems of consciousness
are things like explaining
behaviors which are associated how can
we walk how can we talk i get a stimulus
i can point to it i can act on it i can
report it i can say yeah there's a red
object over there
we got a bead on how to explain those
things in terms of physical processes
in the brain specify a mechanism show
how it does the job but those were the
easy problems the hard problem is why is
all that accompanied by subjective
experience why doesn't it all go on in
the dark
without any subjective experience at all
i mean it doesn't at least in me i know
that i'm conscious i experience all this
and i assume it does for you as well but
why does it right now right now we don't
know that's a hard problem
yeah and you refer to work done um by
thomas nagel and others and i want to
write a book you know my dream dave
maybe with your help i want to write a
book what is it like to be thomas nagle
uh and the author would be a bat because
you know i think a lot of these things
you know to physicists tend to be a
little bit unsatisfying in other words
we um we kind of really tie into the
physical the boltzmann brain aspects
we'll get into that the it from bit and
i think the more interesting you know
a bit from it
but uh but you know how do we how do we
understand at a core grasp you know and
reconcile things that are kind of this
yes subjective and i want to maybe begin
the the core conversation by talking
about this kind of
maybe uh fitful tension between
physicists and uh and philosophers so a
famous quote by galileo when he invented
not the telescope but he perfected the
galilean telescope here's an example of
one um he didn't invent it but he used
it for the first time astronomically and
what he said he did with it is resolve
questions that had vexed philosophers
for many generations and caused them
unending suffering in other words he was
kind of like pejoratively putting down
uh philosophers and nowadays we see it
in people like lawrence krauss and
others and talking about the utility or
lack thereof why is there a tension
between physics and philosophy and do
philosophers have antipathy towards uh
those of my ilk physicists
i don't think so and i don't think there
has to be a tension here
at all i mean the great physicists of
the past many of them were great
philosophers you know isaac newton
considered himself a philosopher he was
professor of natural
philosophy but i mean along the way
and when he was born the problems of
space and time were problems for a
philosopher now newton was a good enough
philosopher that he managed to make
progress on this on this problem with
new methods formal methods experimental
methods that would basically
turn this problem of philosophy into
something we could make progress on
and thereby kind of burst the core of
the science of physics and this happens
in philosophy all along
so many times you know disciplines like
economics psychology
linguistics
parts of logic kind of started as
philosophy some philosopher made
progress on it and then we okay then we
spin off the science okay so now what's
happened is that a number of these a lot
of philosophers have been successful
enough that we now have
the successful spin-off going in physics
in psychology in linguistics and so on
and what's left in philosophy almost by
nature is the too hard basket the stuff
that we haven't figured out how to turn
into a science yet but on the other hand
there's quite a lot of things which are
just to the interface and i would like
to think the science of consciousness is
precisely one of those
starting with a very core
philosophical question how could there
be consciousness in a physical universe
and we're managing to uh to at least
bite bits and pieces of it off so we now
have a thriving science of consciousness
that involves neuroscientists
psychologists and also philosophers
right around
right around that borderline and there
are still bits of the science of the
study of consciousness which are in the
philosophy camp but bits
in the science camp and actually my
experience is i've had a lot of
great experience interacting with
neuroscientists psychologists right now
i've got a big
project with a number of neuroscientists
where we're trying to design experiments
to test some of the leading
philosophical theories of consciousness
and come up with uh
with experiments that will that will do
that so yeah historically look at all
the physicists who were great
philosophers heisenberg schrodinger or
einstein early first half of the 20th
century they were all great philosophers
one thing that happens over time is that
things get a bit more professionalized
maybe you know physicists have to focus
a little bit more these days and some
philosophers focus a bit more so
there's less room for for maybe there's
a bit less of that kind of crossover but
still there's so many physicists who are
who are
brilliant philosophers
too you know john wheeler was a
brilliant philosopher look now someone
like max tegmark wrote you know the
mathematical universe that's a great
work
of philosophy people like david deutsch
who are at the interface
between the two uh philosophers like
david albert and tim maudlin who know
who know physics forward and backwards
so i still think there's a real
productive clause there yeah i would
agree and i mean if they look at the
root of the words meaning you know love
of wisdom love of knowledge i think
that's uh that's something that
physicists should aspire to of course
yeah as you say we have to focus we have
to niche down we have to choose a you
know a profession and so forth so
typically those questions i call them
the 3 a.m dorm room couch questions you
know those kind of dissipating as we
mature and then people look back with
somewhat of disdain you know or just
like oh you know david the first
exposure i had in college of philosophy
was you know philosophy 101 my first day
of freshman year at case western reserve
university and then the professor was
this guy who looked like you know the
the professor and welcome back cotter uh
his name i think was even cotter
something like that and uh he had never
taught before and we would just have
these you know infinitely long exams on
on a quarter you know on a
bi-monthly basis and they were all true
false it was like you know the the
categorical imperative is something that
can subsume the ontological is true i
don't know and i would get less than a
58 on each quit i don't understand how
that's possible it was only it was only
50 50 choice but uh but to recapitulate
one thing you said is that i mean some
of these things are coming back
and really providing a sound basis for
physics research in other words they're
encountering aspects of the multiverse
of alien worlds in this in this book
certainly of the substrate dependence or
lack thereof all topics we're going to
get into and i want to start with this
uh kind of uh really amusing section in
the book where you you go through kind
of what i call uh the char well i'm
gonna call i'm gonna hope this trends
but i'm gonna call it the chalmers
equation and it's kind of the drake
equation but for the probability of
simulation to exist in virtual worlds to
exist and you go through all the
different kind of steps in exactly the
way that frank drake 60 years ago this
year came up with his eponymous drake
equation which is to settle on the
number of you know alien civilizations
that could potentially have
extraterrestrial intelligence um and of
course that's still an open question you
know paul davies who was on the show
recently
wrote a book called the eerie silence
you know the fermi paradox why don't we
see them um i wondered was that kind of
an inspiration for the you know you
don't call it the chalmers equation but
it's sort of uh of the same vein is it
not
yeah it is kind of a similar statistical
equation here i guess i'm thinking about
the number of simulations i should say
that here i got a lot of inspiration
from the philosopher nick bostrom who's
thought about the simulation himself and
he comes up with his own
equation for uh what fraction of beings
in the universe we should expect will be
simulated and uh
he ties it to some complicated things
like the number of beings who become
post-human and so on i don't fully agree
with uh with how bostrom does it which
is why i come up with
with my own way of of coming out of it
but the equation takes a fairly similar
form first we need to
take the probability
there's this background assumption which
is
you know
the question is if you had to simulate
how many universes how many beings
how many simulated beings are going to
have consciousness just like mine in the
history
of the universe
well one assumption there is that
simulated beings can be conscious at all
i don't know how likely is that not
everyone is going to grant that but i
say okay let's grant that i think it's
at least 50 probability
that uh simulated beings can be
conscious at all put your own uh put
your own probability there then
conditional
on simulated conscious beings being
possible what i call simulated
human-like conscious beings being
possible beings with experience like us
what is the probability that there will
be many of them that they will greatly
outnumber
humans
and well again that depends on some
assumptions it depends on beings getting
to the point where they can have the
capacity to build these beings and that
they will choose
to build them i say okay let's give that
at least whatever whatever probability
you get for that i say let's give it at
least
50
multiply those out you then get a 25
chance that most beings with
conscious experiences like mine are
themselves simulated beings
and then running
running the probabilities a little bit
further you basically get just under 25
percent chance that i'm in myself in a
simulation
but okay that's a that's just a back of
the envelope case but it's the back of
the envelope case for 25 chance we're in
a simulation if you wanted to be more
conservative you could dial some of
those back to one in 10 and you still
get a 100 chance and that's at least
interesting yeah as i always say though
i gave a talk and you know maybe enemy
territory i spoke at the seti institute
six years ago now maybe and i laid out a
case for you know my my complaints
against the drake equation and this is
at the institute that frank drake and
jill tardino built so i had to tread
kind of carefully but i said you know to
scientists like like myself the number
is is interesting but the error bars are
much more important because the error
bars subsume all your ignorance all your
uncertainties all the model dependencies
all the calibration biases etc etc and i
went through an example where i
calculated let's do the drake equation
for how many people are in the world
famous san diego zoo down the road for
me at this very moment i go through the
calculation people can see it on youtube
at seti institute's website our youtube
channel
and i come up with a number and i come
up with a number of people there it's
like eight thousand but the uncertainty
was plus or minus twelve thousand and it
could be negative people there could be
holes and
virtual people you know and and kind of
suffusing the void there uh so the point
being that the error bars are you know
in some cases more important than the
number itself so what would you ascribe
the error bar on either the 25 or the
hundred percent or the one percent um
you know some people say it's even much
higher uh that than either one of those
two numbers you know the 25 so talk
about the errors in that calculation
which is what really matters to
scientists in the end
yeah and in fact in this case the error
bars in a way play in my favor because
the conclusion i want to argue for here
is that we don't know
that we're not in a simulation that we
can't rule it out so to the extent that
there's a whole lot of uncertainty here
well that just increases the likelihood
that yeah we don't know there are
possibilities here
we can't exclude but i agree that
there's all kinds of
uncertainty here one one source of
uncertainty is just on the consciousness
side right we don't understand
consciousness
so we don't know whether a simulated
being could be conscious at all i go 50
50 but someone might say come on
well i believe that maybe that's a maybe
that's that's under 10
another source of uncertainty is whether
simulated universes will be possible
will the laws of physics ultimately be
be computational of course roger penrose
thinks that the laws of physics are not
computable so we'll never have a
simulation of the universe at least on a
classical computer i mean at this point
i'd like to think that even if a
classical computer can't do it can't do
it just say you know penrose is right
that the true theory of quantum gravity
will have some non-computable element in
it i'd like to think that whatever that
element is
we could then you know we could then
capture that element and use that to
build new computers quantum gravity
computers that would thereby exploit
this this non-computable element and we
could get universe simulations that way
but okay there's a big source of
uncertainty there and the third
is less
is maybe tied to the sociology tied to
the future is it the case
that we will actually have beings even
though these simulations could exist is
it the case we'll get to the point where
we have beings who can build them and do
build them
maybe all the beings of the future will
be
will be uh self-protective enough maybe
that they choose nepno to create
advanced
general artificial general intelligence
thinking that this is just too dangerous
or maybe they'll be ethical enough to
say man we can't create these simulated
universes that would be
playing god so yeah maybe this
sociological part is probably the most
uncertain of them all i mean i'm just
thinking that
naively these populations will be
gung-ho someone's going to do it
eventually it's going to be useful for
all these purposes help predict the
future help understand the world
scientists love to run simulations now
so much science is simulation based once
we can simulate the whole universe
of course scientists are going to want
to run some universe simulations
to see what happens but who knows maybe
that maybe the the institutional review
boards will come in with the grants will
be
you know from the galactic science
foundation right
um but in the case of the drake equation
what a lot of people point to is
excessive things like the kepler mission
and calculating the number and observing
actually real data unlike um you know
some some branches of of uh really
theoretical physics um like string
theory or whatever or very little data
actually exists and it's all
retro-addictive and not predictive but
but in any case i'm not going to go off
on a polemic about string theory right
now but on the other hand we've reduced
some of these terms in the uh in the
drake equation to basically what i call
the only thing that's remaining are the
sociological terms and then the lifetime
you go through this really and it's just
such a great book i can't recommend it
highly enough especially for my fellow
physicists and those nerds uh like me
out there because dave goes through in
great detail but it's so entertaining
this notion of well what is the brain
viewed as a super computer and you know
we had this notion uh that the brain
human brain is so far surpassing it's
got more neurons and connections between
neurons than there are you know galaxies
in the observed bulb universe et cetera
et cetera
and yet you make a very uh convincing uh
calculation that the human brain is sort
of equivalent to a 10 petaflop computer
right now and there are computers that
we use to analyze data from the universe
the cosmic microwave background owned by
the department of energy that are 10
petaflop computers you know or you know
that scale and that's what 60 years
after general you know turing machines
were kind of first conjectured by alan
turing and and suffered by neumann and
others so in such a short amount of time
we're already surpassing in raw
computation power
and that's one of the terms i think that
would have to go into a chalmers
equation for calculating the number of
stimuli so what other things remain as i
said the sociological term the lifetime
of intelligence civilizations before
they blow themselves apart create some
runaway ai
create some virus or whatever those
that's the limiting factor in our
understanding and the maximum
contributor to our error bars
what is in the chalmers equation
again you don't call it that but i can
call it that uh
what is what is the the limiting factor
and what have we learned most um most
recently you know from analogs of you
know consciousness kepler's or so forth
like what are the current experimental
and theoretical computer science or
sociological
terms that have shrunk the error bars in
that equation
that's interesting um
yeah i guess on the uh
the first factor there's like as
simulated consciousness possible a
simulated physics possible and the
limiting factors there are going to be
tied to our knowledge of consciousness
and of physics
on the sociological side
there's going to be um
will we get to the point where we can
make these and will we choose
to uh to make them but maybe yeah the
technology side is interesting i mean
yeah
the exact number of petaflops required
to simulate a brain or a universe i mean
in certain respects you might say the
simulation argument doesn't need overly
strong arguments here just say it's a
vast amount that's required because we
don't need to hypothesize that the
universe in which the simulation is run
is the same as ours it seems actually
very likely it might be quite different
might be quite different from ours and i
mean obviously
if the universe is finite there's pretty
good reason to think no universe no
finite universe can run a perfect
simulation of itself but
some people say ah therefore the
simulation hypothesis is bunk but of
course the relevant hypothesis is the
complex universes can run simulations of
simpler universes or parts of themselves
and so on we also should hold open the
possibility that the simulating universe
is infinite
let's find different laws of physics
from ours perhaps and that is somehow
trivial in these infinite universes with
infinite resources
to uh to create universes with even
with with
finite resources such as uh such as our
own appears to be at least in the known
universe
um so from that perspective it's like
even if those resource bounds
don't hold then all we need to do is
move to say for example the infinite
simulation hypothesis and we should
still give some
probability to that but it is
interesting that actually simulation
technology has been moving along very
very fast
in recent years both you know people
actually build cosmic simulations and uh
and yeah every every few years that
cosmic simulations
get a whole lot more uh get a whole lot
more detailed and more fine-grained and
yeah they're
multi-scale simulations are becoming
more and more
more and more of a thing and then from
the bottom up it's like well virtual
reality technology is also
developing for me that's it's very
relevant that actually we now have these
simulations that we can enter and
experience immersively those are not yet
vr is not yet a copy of the physical
world but if vr just gets better and
better for 50 years or 100 years we'll
probably have the version of vr which is
indistinguishable from the physical
world once we have that technology in
front of us we will actually be able to
put people into simulations that feel
like they're
simulations of physical reality at that
point no one's going to be able to say
hey this is just way out this is science
fiction we're actually going to have the
technology in front of us it'll be
happening to some people and we can then
raise the question maybe just that is
happening to us now some people say
oh isn't the simulation hypothesis
meaningless because it's unverifiable or
undetectable once we can actually put
people into these simulations no one can
say it's meaningless anymore it's like
we've got ours i've got it right here so
i'm gonna now strap on my my oculus you
have one there too dave we can uh we can
enter into vr
right here interview with uh cassandra
tien here in uh uc san diego for the
arthur c clarke center and arthur c
clarke makes an appearance in the in
your book as well uh one of his books of
childhood end i believe you quote from
which presage is an ocean of vr and and
uh and computer simulation and so forth
uh but now this isn't super realistic
you know when i'm when i put these on in
fact i've tried to use it for you know
to do exercise and then as you get all
these cookies and i try to use it for
meditation and it's like blindingly
bright and i'm taking you have a more
recent uh version than i do
mine is the oculus it's just the oculus
go i think from three years ago which is
totally outdated
you have the quest
yeah i mean they're common
yeah
there's there's the fundamental problem
with them and and that you know that
you're wearing this giant thing and as
we know now i don't know if you've
checked you know your ira or or whatever
but you know facebook which is now known
as meta you know for the metaverse is
cratering and going you know going down
which is making a lot of people really
happy uh but uh that's sort of a virtual
where you could put this on you can talk
to your facebook friends maybe but it's
it's so cumbersome and even if you use
your voice it's kind of cumbersome now i
mentioned galileo before
it turns out galileo may have been the
first person to invent a vr or maybe an
ar headset uh because he there was the
problem of computing time as you know in
the in the 16th and 1700s and there was
this longitude prize that was offered
for the first kind of reliable clock and
galileo said well hey wait a second i've
got this telescope and i can see the
moons of jupiter and there as periodic
as you would like them to be and in fact
you can see them you know all over the
earth and so he invented this helmet
with two telesco or one telescope
attached called like a chronoscope or
something like that and uh he used it to
you know trying to claim the longitude
wise uh and of course it was rejected
because people say oh you can only see
the moons you know nine months out of
the year and what do you do those other
months he's like well you could you know
calculate tables and interpolate but um
but you know back then if you look at
well how much has really changed in
augmented reality now i can you know go
to ikea's website i can take a picture
of my you know carpet and then i'll
suggest it how a chair will look um it's
kind of being used as facebook's using
it for like advertising and i wonder
when we scale up these digital computers
as i understand it moore's law
starts to uh deteriorate because as the
power of the computer grows and it does
grow at this exponential rate the number
of use cases the number of users and the
demands that they're putting on it are
always scratching you know the upper
bound of the envelope so you in other
words you're you're almost like the the
utility of them becomes so much higher
in addition to their raw power
and it and it's growing at a rate that's
you know sort of causing their bounds to
saturate when it comes to the actual
number of let's say output and you could
distill that into any term not just
petaflops but into how many papers get
written how many you know full
simulations come to conclusion and those
are actually tapering off for these
large supercomputers and so we have to
keep building more and more so that the
plateau gets higher and higher can you
see that as a term in the chalmers
equation that would eventually limit the
you know kind of optimistic prospects of
a you know world in which we are already
living in such a simulation
yeah totally especially if we're talking
about yeah building ultimate full
simulations of the human brain
full
ground level simulations of physics um
yeah in the book i give some
calculations that require that rely on
something like moore's law
continuing so yeah every decade we get
this multiplication factor and given
that
it's not too hard to say okay i'm a
philosopher i take the long view i don't
care what happens in the next 10 years i
care
what happens
what happens eventually but 100 years
200 years i'm fine as long as it
continues but yeah if it asymptotes at
some point then obviously there are
serious uh there are serious potential
limitations there i mean i kind of hope
then at a certain point we get to
harness the power of the sun and do
amazing things we uh
things that we couldn't do before
but um yeah if it turns out there are
principle limits then i mean you know we
know their current physics has
principled limits like the speed of
light and the planck scale and so on
so either we eventually
if we eventually hit them then i think
we need to get more creative on the uh
on the software side so to speak if we
have
ultimate hardware limitations then we do
things on the on the software side for
example we find speed ups and shortcuts
in our simulation as people do already
maybe people will find ways where okay
we're only going to simulate local parts
of the universe okay simulating the
whole universe out of reach let's just
simulate the solar system in detail and
everything else is just kind of a
sketchy background copy it'll obey a few
basic principles of cosmology and not
too much hey that could have been what
messed up those experiments years ago
exactly in addition to the dust that you
talked about at the end of the book uh
we'll get into that um so you mentioned
you know roger penrose is a three or
four time uh guest on uh into the
impossible and yeah you're right he does
talk about the limits of computability
and his apocal book the emperor's new
mind which is the first science book i
ever read and it was kind of a treat to
have him endorse my first book uh way
back when before he won a nobel prize uh
and uh and and it's quite interesting
and he and i have talked and others have
talked about this notion of ai
physicists so you know what is the
limitation of and our friend max mark
who's also a guest and friend um you
know he's very sanguine about a.i
feinman ai galileo ai but i i always
remind folks i say you know what um i
don't know if you're familiar uh with
this dave but um einstein called the
happiest thought of his life and i've
got a little einstein a virtual einstein
here he is my guest my uh
audience always loves when i break out
the the virtual uh areas
so yeah i only have one of these that
has uh actually been on the show and
that's noam chomsky uh but maybe someday
there'll be a chalmers finger puppet
from the unemployed philosopher's guild
this is this is this is called the
unemployed philosophers girl yeah who
knew that einstein was a
so einstein was speaking about uh the
equivalence principle which undergirds
all of general relativity and he said um
he described what he called the happiest
thought of his life
and that was that an observer you know
freely falling in space would experience
no gravitational field meaning that you
know gravity and acceleration are you
know one
and the same and that geodesics are
manifestations of the shortest paths in
a curvature free space time and they're
only adding curvature due to gravitating
mass then it changes and alters the
perception of both spatial intervals and
time but um i posit to you
that i don't believe it's possible for
an ai
einstein to exist because i mean first
of all how do you how do you visualize
the notion of free fall as a silicon
based uh entity and then two what does
it mean to be happy like what what does
an ai mean when when he or she or it or
z or
whatever feels happy so isn't that you
know kind of a counter you know proof
that we could ever come up with a
computer you know simulator could come
up with such laws that the human brain
has done over and over again
i don't know i think the human brain is
a big complex machine it's an amazing
machine it's a creative machine but it's
still made up of these neurons which are
appear to be computational units hooked
up in amazing ways it can learn
in amazing ways the imagination
as far as we can tell is itself a kind
of
simulation when we imagine things when
einstein was imagining things in free
fall he was running a kind of simulation
himself running on this incredible
this incredible computer which is far
more sophisticated than any computer
that we ourselves have developed to date
but you know ai is moving fast i can't
believe where it is now compared to
where it was 10 years ago i did my phd
in an ai lab in the 1990s with uh with
dark hofstadter and back then people
used to say
a year spent working in ai a year spent
working in ai is enough to make you
believe in god
because ai is so hard it's so hard to
get machines to do
human level sophisticated things but
suddenly in the last 10 years
yeah machines doing image recognition
they're doing speech recognition they're
doing speech generation they're doing
game playing they're doing navigation
they're writing their own code they're
suddenly all these hurdles are
hurdles of falling and yeah i mean we
don't if we don't remotely have an ai
einstein yet but i'm not going to be the
one who bets against it in 20 or 30
years time and yeah we do have emotion
is certainly a limiting factor in
ai right now but we do have
computational models of emotion at least
treating happiness and sadness as forms
of valence and i don't think anyone
would claim that we yet
have ai systems that experience
genuine emotion but i don't see the
principle limit towards ais ultimately
there are what they call affective
computing is a field and people are
working on this
um
machines can be made to behave in
certain ways which at least seem to
reflect irritation satisfaction
frustration big question are they really
experiencing it well that's a question
about consciousness right so my late
father used to say well if you want to
simulate you know pleasure and pain
response which is you know some
psychologists and social philosophers
claim that's you know all we're
responding to as conscious entities uh
he's my father used to say yo well just
like when it does something wrong you
know you blow a transistor or you you
know you could you know collapse a wave
function if it's a quantum you know do
something that is a painful you know
cost function for that computer it's
still not clear how to you know simulate
you know happiness and and free fall is
it really the some totality of of only
pleasure with no pain i mean obviously
we can have superpositions you know
right now i'm really happy but i could
be you know unhappy very easily and i
could be much happier very easily too so
it's not is it clear that i have to be
in the ultimate state of happiness to
experience it you mentioned god you
mentioned you know believing in god is
kind of off but but i do feel like you
know it's pretty remarkable that these
you know bronze age you know itinerant
semitic wanderers you know three
thousand years ago uh it you know came
up with a notion of you know pleasure
pain experience reality free will
commandments moral and ethical
imperatives you know 3000 years ago were
they creating uh the you know the
earliest version of the sim hypothesis
yeah well human beings are amazing and
we've got i don't know how far back some
of these simulation ideas go but you can
find elements of it ancient chinese
philosophy
and his butterfly how do i know i'm not
a butterfly
dreaming that he's drawing that that is
where by the way that's where the
butterfly and the uh on the cover came
from that is uh meant to be a virtual
reality version of
ange's butterfly
i could be uh it could be a butterfly
dreaming he's he's drawing you find an
indian philosophy of ideas about
um ideas about illusion
so many um the hindu tradition has god's
mind supporting all of reality and maybe
this
also connects to what you find in the uh
in the abrahamic
traditions
um where yeah giant
um god is so all-powerful god supports
uh god supports reality and of course
the question is how did god create
reality i guess i i always remember let
there be light
and there was a and there was light in
the book i
i i speculated about maybe what actually
went home was let there be bits
and god creates some god creates some
bits the difference no actually exactly
so
in the talmudic tradition that i'm more
familiar with um what god does in the
first six days of creation is separate
so the second line after let there be
light or information and everyone say it
is uh and the world was chaos and void
and he created order so in other words
there's chaos which could be a state
like a one and there's order which would
be lower entropy could be a zero and and
he separates between man and animal
between vegetation
water and land uh and so it's not at all
a stretch to to hypothe hypothesize that
that is yeah there you go yeah show that
that's
yeah
i got a great illustration of this in
the uh in the book on one side we have
there is a traditional god
creating the universe by uh creating
some bits and then the uh the tables and
chairs and animals and everything else
come from there on the on the other side
we have a simulator
uh a simulator god who here is like a
teenage girl on the next universe up
she's creating reality by programming
her computer to create bits that that
create the trees and dolphins and and i
mean
you know stipulated i believe you only
need zeros and ones and you talk about
um there's a leibniz who also yeah came
up with the primitive boolean
construction so yeah you only need these
you know fundamental units chaos and
order if you like um and so it's not
altogether um you know impossible even
to be in you know some sort of resonance
with a traditional religious um you know
conception and so i saw a funny thing in
one of these like onion type magazines
it was like you know scientists praise
god for creating an ultra realistic
metaverse that he calls the universe
but um
i want to ask you if there's a very very
provocative middle section of the book
where you start talking you basically
make the claim that a creator
plus it from bit
equals a simulation
and yet you still personally don't
believe that such a god is worthy of
worship nor do you worship an ordinary
abrahamic or other faith creator um you
also don't believe that is necessary or
worthy of worship potentially so but
before we go there dave i want to ask
you um what is it from bit and why is it
so central it's a wheeler-ism uh like
many things uh but how do you
instantiate you know a computer program
um from the absence of a computer
program i've had on and i'll ask you to
kind of um steel man
my opponent or maybe your opponent's
ideas but if you're if you're game but
you know i've had on intelligent
designers i've had on people that
believe in god believe in
creation and and even people like michio
kaku is your you know fellow new york
professor down there somewhere in new
york city but this notion that um that
there's nothing we've ever discovered
that can't be traced in some way to
something with a design that contains
information in other words there's life
and you could say well life didn't come
but something that has an information
content a bit
that is not associated with a
you know a mind in some sense a computer
program written by itself doesn't exist
a hieroglyphic on a cave doesn't exist
without a person but first
despite that long preamble what is it
from bit and then we'll get into the
creation aspects of it
yeah well it from bit is a slogan from
the physicist john wheeler who basically
said maybe you know the fundamental
level of reality what there is is the
difference between two different answers
to a question yes or no
one or zero and wheeler took this in a
certain direction towards the
participatory universe where
observation plays a central role
that kind of gets you into the role of
the mind and the foundations of physics
but the direction that i want to take it
in which a lot of people want to take is
just the idea that at the bottom level
of physics there could be something
digital like uh ones and zeros binary
states we have this wonderful example of
this that so many people know which is
john conway's game of life which is a
cellular automaton it's basically a
two-dimensional universe with a whole
bunch of cells each of which can be in
one of two states they can be on
they can be off and we've got these very
simple rules that you know a cell turns
on if three of its neighbors are on and
it turns off
if there are too few or too many
neighbors and from those basic laws of
binary physics of digital physics
we can generate all kinds of behavior
and from this you know many people have
speculated
that okay there's so many forms digital
physics could take maybe even our world
has a level of digital physics
underneath standard physics and my
my sense of this is that most physicists
don't take this terribly seriously as a
as a working hypothesis it goes way
beyond any evidence we have now there
are people like stephen wolfram who are
developing ideas in the vicinity but i
don't need it to be true i just need it
to be kind of a coherent
a coherent hypothesis
most importantly you know these digital
worlds they're not worlds where nothing
is real they're not worlds where things
are an illusion
they're worlds where things are
ultimately digital but which is
important for me because
it means at the very least that just
because something is digital doesn't
mean we should say it isn't real a big
central theme in this book is that
digital objects can be real
too and if we're in a simulation so if
so one thing i want to say is if we're
in a simulation we shouldn't say the
objects around us aren't real rather we
should say they're digital which is to
say you know if we're in our simulation
we've got tables we've got chairs we've
got molecules atoms quarks underneath
them and underneath those
we have bits this is to say that if
we're in a simulation universe we're
really in a kind of it from bit universe
with some digital level underlying all
these analog levels that we experience
bits underneath physics so that's how
the that's the it from bit idea and how
it connects to the simulation idea and
then yeah the next question of course is
how it connects to the creation right so
in the book you say creation plus it
from bit equals the simulation
hypothesis so where does that uh how can
we uh reconcile that statement uh
equation so to speak
yeah it's interesting i was always a bit
skeptical about uh about creators and
creation
most of my life i've considered myself
an atheist not particularly religious
don't believe in a god the whole god
idea seems somewhat
supernatural to me but once you start
thinking about simulations and the
simulation hypothesis suddenly there's a
root to thinking about gods or at least
creators that no longer seem so
supernatural just an entirely natural
way
of thinking about gods just as the
creator of a simulation you know we can
create simulations
in our own world now without needing any
supernatural powers so the thought is
well maybe somebody in some universe
created this universe
as a simulation but if you have a
simulation and it looks like you need a
simulator you need some kind of agent
to
to create it and then that simulator
well i don't want to call the simulator
of god or a god but simulator the
simulator has at least some of the
traditional properties
of a god they created this world
they are potentially all-powerful about
this world presumably they can affect
all kinds of things that potentially
all-knowing about this world those are
three of the central properties
of a traditional traditional god now
there are some other properties the
simulator might not have
being all good or all wise no particular
reason to think the simulator has to be
especially good
or especially wise
um
maybe they didn't create the entire
cosmos either they created this bit of
the cosmos in some ways that's more like
what sometimes called a demiurge in some
religious traditions like a sub god that
created at least this part of reality
for us they fashioned it
as a kind of uh as a kind of
constructive
creator
so
most importantly i would not recommend
that we
that we erect a religion around the
simulator i don't think this being
is somebody we should worship i don't
think we should expect this being to
have any special
moral
insight so for reasons like that i'm
uncomfortable describing the simulator
even if i believed we were in a
simulation i'd be uncomfortable
describing the simulator
as a god but nevertheless you know it's
a way of getting some of the properties
of a traditional god and yeah and it
combines with a it from bit idea because
after all
how does the simulator set up the
simulation by arranging a computer
program by arranging the bits so what i
want to say is if we're in
a simulation then yeah the it from bit
hypothesis is true it's all made of bits
and all that was put there by a
simulator by a creator so basically the
simulation hypothesis
equals
the it from bit hypothesis plus the
creation hypothesis
equation pretty pretty simple uh i like
it the elegance and simplicity um so to
push back with a little respect uh as
you know i have for you um if you think
about you know
a god as being worthy of worship what
would it take for such a simulator or
abrahamic deity in other words what
would it take
for you personally to
find such an entity worthy or is there
no combination of trades properties
behaviors that would make any simulated
or actual god worthy of david
charlemoner's respect or worship rather
i would greatly ris their beings i would
greatly respect i would have awe for you
know whether it's a simulator or a
non-simulator someone who created the
universe and
understood
so many things if they have knowledge
and understanding and power that goes
far beyond ours i would have
the most enormous respect admiration and
awe but i don't think i would worship
them maybe i guess i just don't really
understand
worship and why it's ever appropriate
this is an amazing being that uh
that i would find yeah fully uh
fully awesome but worshiping them it's
like a special why would i
worship them is it like are they the
source of all
moral truth i guess i know it's i don't
really see why that would be true i'd
it's a bit like my attitude to god would
be like my attitude to einstein but
squared cube to the myth
so
it has to be something of benevolence
and there's often times uh you know
there is no commandment uh in the hebrew
bible which is the root of the christian
bible obviously you know that uh there's
no commandment to to worship god there's
no commandment to believe in god
there's a commandment to love god and i
always say you know you don't get
commanded to do things that are natural
like i don't have to command you you
know dave to to eat whatever kind of
burger vegan or meat that you like
because you like to do it it's fun right
it tastes good for people that have
children i don't have to be commanded to
love my kids it's totally natural the
other hand you have to be commanded to
love something that's inherently
unlovable so in the in the biblical
tradition god recognizes that he is not
lovable that he is there are things
about what he's doing and there is
authority that by its nature is not you
know as anathema to some aspects of
creatures such as we who have free will
and i think that is the divine thing
that we are endowed with free will
unlike animals we're the only creatures
that are mentioned creations that are
mentioned that no good from evil no life
from death know that we will die in fact
that's what you know homo sapien really
is referring to so i think worship is
the wrong word and i think it's a myth
let's let's like the translation the the
um you know the sixth commandment
most people say thou shalt not kill
right i mean
you might you might have been familiar
with it's not thou shalt not kill of
course god does a lot of killing we're
instructed to kill all sorts of people
but thou shalt not murder which is
stealing of a life so there's a lot of
king james translations one of them is
worship and i think the real term should
be awe and it's sort of you know in the
way i have conceived of it as coming
later in life back to judaism which was
my roots is that god should be
visualized kind of like a parent a
father you know unlike the graduate
student girl that's uh the pre the hero
of your book uh the god goddess of your
book but um but it's it's sort of like
your father something a paternalistic
figure uh that is worthy of awe but a
little bit of fear so it's like your
father's the king
and uh and you're close to him and he
cares about you and it is a personal god
which i have issues with you know just
believing in the supernatural suspension
of all the laws of physics for brian
keating but there's something one of my
rabbis once said he's like you know well
if you were god i'll ask you dave you
know but he said you know if you were
god what would you be doing and and i
assume i don't know i said what would
you be doing he said he said the exact
same thing that's happening right now
you think i know more than god you know
it's like things are are behaving in a
certain way and for us you know it's a
little bit of hubris and you don't have
to respond to this if you don't want to
but but the notion that you know we
should believe in god like oh wait god's
waiting for brian keating or david
chalmers you know if he exists if it
exists you know he really no it's it's
more does god you know believe in us so
to speak are we acting in accord with
accordance with those principles that
will create flourishing or minimize harm
and crowds the greatest amount of
pleasure so i think that's the moral
term the word in hebrew is conveyed it
means to respect or make heavy and
that's also what you must do with your
parents so you can respond if you like i
i don't you know we don't need to
continue on this rain though
yeah
no respect and all our attitudes i have
attitudes of respect and all to many
human beings i've got respect and awe
for einstein i've got
respect and awe for you know nelson
mandela
respect and law for beyonce it's like
in in very different ways um and it's
like totally if if i believed that there
was this god who created the universe
and showed themselves to have amazing
wisdom and amazing power that i would
have i would have respect and all for
that being uh something something not
something short of worship i mean
and if our simulators turn out to have
those properties maybe they're going to
turn out to be super intelligent ais or
something i could i'd have respect and
all
for that as well but if they start
behaving like um
you know they start raining down death
and destruction then i'm going to worry
actually i got into this when um i
probably got into this idea when i came
across my five-year-old nephew
playing a game like uh like simcity and
he would he would show me he would build
up these worlds and these
these cities and these forests and
everything and then he said
now's the fun part
and he
sets them all on fire
kill all those people they're gone
they're gone
that is kind of curiously reminiscent of
the old testament god right yeah
so i thought yeah that's besides i'm
thinking my god is not gonna
if i'm if i'm gonna if i'm gonna have
respect and law for a
for a god i hope that uh yeah they're
gonna be they're gonna be much more the
way that you were describing the god
they're not going to care whether we
worship them they're not going to uh
they get they may they're going to rain
down death and destruction but they're
going to try and set things up right
yeah exactly so
there's a lot of that and also i often
you know point out to people they say oh
you know scientists should run the world
you know scientists embody you know the
best aspects of humanity and you know
you're so childlike and and it's
wonderful to see someone and i say yeah
you know scientists are like children
we're very inquisitive we're very
curious we're very you know kind of um
you know egotistical in a certain good
way and we also don't play well with
others we don't share our toys with
others we compete like you know it's
like we're selfish we're jealous we're
petty yeah so it's like there's no
single i always say there's no
single-edged swords out there it's all
they're all double-edged swords every
blessing comes with a curse and one of
the curses of of such a god is yeah is
that temptation that involuntary
volitional or otherwise you know like
what happens if i you know take away or
put this little tiny virus out there and
we'll see what happens
and we could talk theodicy some other
time but i want to get back to the book
um you know when i'm reading the book
i'm thinking um let's say there is the
simulation um i know my audi and we're
going to take audience questions i have
stored up uh from you know over a
hundred uh responses to you generously
sharing your time on the podcast uh but
one thing you know they want to know and
they're screaming out is why um and i
know it's not a kosher scientific
question ask why but why would there why
would they simulate anything in other
words you know the talmudic rabbis of
2000 years ago you know came to a
conclusion that god shouldn't have
created the world like it caused more
problems than itself so why why is there
a simulation why what is the is there
you know is there a teleological purpose
for such a universe
i don't know why do we create
simulations i mean we create a lot of
simulations like simulated worlds now
already i guess right now there are
maybe two
overarching
purposes uh one is entertainment
simulations of video game worlds and so
on there's a vast
entertainment industry and the other one
is science uh people like running uh
scientists like running
uh simulations now to understand the
systems that they're working with
whether it's the uh the cosmos or
traffic patterns in the city or water
flow everyone is doing science with
simulations it's easy to imagine
that both reasons could be reasons why
people might eventually create simulated
universes do science run the simulation
many times
pick up the statistics see how often
life develops hey you want to study that
those drake equation issues let's see
how often life actually develops given
certain laws of physics
and how often intelligence develops and
so on so that's one good reason yeah
entertainment is another or a third is
predicting the future you know we run
simulations to predict
what will happen whether it's a military
simulation or a financial simulation or
this
or
that episode of black mirror where a
couple there's an app that a couple can
run run a whole bunch of simulation of
the simulations of their relationships
to see if they're uh to see if they're
compatible
actually it's the sidebar on this is
i've come to think that using simulation
technology for predictive purposes is
actually
very difficult especially for social
predictive purposes because do you
simulate the simulation technology
or not like do the people in that black
mirror episode when they run when they
go out on dates
simulations all the way down
i think you mentioned simulator
yeah
but if you do that then of course you
know the simulations they're running
themselves gonna have to have
simulations and you're to basically have
an infinite regress the alternative is
at some point just simulate worlds where
they don't have simulation technology
that's going to be totally unreliable
two people could be totally compatible
in a world without the technology but
the technology will ruin it for them and
more generally i think this is this is
going to be a regress for any
any use any social uses of simulation
technology for predictive it brings up a
lot of uh a little maybe there'll be
something we can go down maybe i'll i'll
start with one you know there's the old
joke you know if you can um
if you can uh simulate being authentic
then you've got it made you know it's
like
you know on the surface he's deep but
you know superficially he's very shallow
right
um so you know deep down all the it from
bit you know there is a certain kernel
of of um and as you mentioned skepticism
among the physics community likewise
stephen wolfram past guest multiple
guests on this show um there's kept this
great skepticism in other words there's
just direct criticism and there's
nothing that's practically relevant to
theories of everything to unification um
there these these things tend the
cellular automata tend to be really good
at simulating the properties of cellular
automata just in the same string theory
is the best theory ever invented to
study the properties of string theory uh
in other words it's very much siloed and
i wonder you know uh is that because of
this you know this this substrate
dependency versus you know you could
get things irreducibly down to
information
but again all instantiations of
computability even if you claim the
human brain is a computer it's still
running on a substrate um how do we get
the substrate where does the substrate
come from or can you have a truly
substrate free and i don't want to have
any spo i hate when authors would or
podcast would have me on their show and
say describe your entire book so my
audience doesn't have to buy no i'm not
going to do that but at the end of
reality plus you talk about the dust
cloud and and so forth and this
fundamental primitive computer but the
conclusion tends to be towards that well
it can contain enough bits you know and
theoretically that it could support a
computational system of you know not
infinite complexity but some limited but
large complexity how do you get the
substrate independence we still need a
substrate
yeah well the substrate could just be
something like like bits pure bits yeah
i don't really actually need the it from
bit hypothesis to make to make this idea
around i think it provides a very vivid
illustration certainly i don't need like
the bits to be
serious physics required for a
unification
for a ground unified theory but it would
be enough if we could have say a ground
unified theory physics and then you know
in the simulation
maybe the bits don't ever actually show
up
in the equations because you know when
you run it i run a simulation of
newtonian physics then if it works well
you'll just see newtonian physics you
won't see the bits right but there is
an insulin or in a cube
there is a matter that has to exist to
run the computer
ah so here we have two versions of the
it from bit idea one is what i call the
pure it from bit idea where the basic
level is bits
and they're not you've got zeros and
ones and there's nothing more basic yeah
the zeros and ones we all know about
they're made of something more basic
they're you know they're
instantiated in voltages on transistors
within circuits
um
so that was what we might call the bit
from it idea the bits the bits that we
actually have on our computers going to
underlying it and that could be you
could combine the it from bit idea from
it
then you get what i call the it from bit
from it
idea objects in our world made of bits
at the underlying level those bits are
made of something more basic maybe for
example there's a computer in the next
universe up
that's uh instantiating those bits with
some analog of voltages in their world
and that'll be it from bit from it and
then the substrate will be the it's in
that world okay then we've got to ask
the question of the it's in that world
made of bits which are made of further
it's
hit from bit from it from bit from it
and on you uh
and on you go but also
one thing is also worth saying is you
don't actually need classical bits
to make this work you can make this work
with uh
with
qubits you know the kind of the kind of
the analog of bits you find in quantum
computing and i think you can also make
it work with um
with continuous bits so what i sometimes
call reals
in the book it actually doesn't have to
be binary physics it could be continuous
physics
the key idea is just kind of a level of
information
underneath everything which could be
binary of information it could be
quantum information or it could even be
a kind of continuous
information it's just i use bits because
that's by far the simplest version of
this idea but i'm not sure that
binariness per se is so important but
the issue you raise of is there a
substrate beneath the information that's
super important because um yeah i think
there's two very different ideas here
and the world of pure information it's a
beautiful vision but it's yeah it's not
totally clear no i agree in fact right
you know i don't know what you mean so i
like to steal man my own arguments from
time to time so one of the things that i
pointed because i'm you know more in the
materialist that you do need a substrate
it's a fundamental issue even the qubits
are
actual matter material particles etc and
those and the forces and fields that
interact between them
but i also will push back on my own
thinking and say well you know the first
operating system by definition was
written without an operating system the
you know assembly language is written
without assembly language uh you know
the first uh the first modern you know
editors are written and word processors
written without word process so um so
there's proof but you know at some level
it is you know increasing the column
agora of complexity etc goes up um and
and you do bootstrap recursively but you
know it's to me it's it's it's it's
difficult to envision without some
fundamental layer of a substrate which
you know comes from physics and the the
issue that i think presents a serious
challenge that you you do address in the
book and you partially alluded to it now
but um is the notion of what we believe
at least is non-computable like so
turing's original 19 you know 56 or
whatever paper or the 48 paper whatever
computable it was on computable numbers
and it was on numbers
that could be
programmed and actually executed by a
universal machine a generalized you know
computing machine and that excluded
things like transcendental numbers or
rational numbers and you just mentioned
continuous real numbers but of course
all the numbers are you know include
transcendental numbers uh and the most
two most important numbers seem to be
um you know numbers that computers have
a very difficult time with in other
words the number zero and the number
infinity if it's a number
pi and e yes no i talk about that but i
thought
you know the middle four digits of pi
are my pin numbers so don't tell anyone
um
because i could lose a lot in my my
university of california savings account
uh but uh but yeah so those are yeah so
uh they are irrational uh numbers we
can't we can't uh square root of two et
cetera uh there's no program that can
can calculate them
for for transcendental numbers and so
they fail that the a turing type machine
cannot produce them but similarly
infinity cannot be really represented on
a computer we can we can you know
approximate it to arbitrary precision uh
but you know if you truly do things that
the human mind is totally capable of
finding you know the uh the
logarithm of uh of negative infinity you
know we could we can think about those
numbers and we can use those numbers
even to construct calculus but how can a
computer of any kind you know capture
this notion of infinity is that
something that's uniquely
relevant to this squishy wet
supercomputer or do you think that
notion will exist even in a simulated
universe and therefore the continuum is
true in other words there'll be an
infinite number of of bits required to
represent the actual universe
yeah well we can maybe we can yeah
infinity is tricky but we can axiomatize
infinity we can kind of get our grasp we
can try to articulate our grasp of
infinity via axioms and yeah in
traditional set theory there is this
axiom of infinity which is a finite
string of symbols that we lay out
different levels of infinity express
our understanding of infinity but
yeah
actually of course what we find actually
is that these axioms for infinity
actually under determine
its uh its nature it's like how many
levels of infinity are there is the
continuum hypothesis true or false is
the one after the integers the reals or
is there a whole bunch in between i mean
you can add axioms to try and uh to try
and determine these matters but then
there's always going to be stuff left
under determined for reasons and the
foundations of
of mathematics so it may be that
we will never get a precise grasp
of infinity through a
finite set of axioms on the other hand
who says that humans have such a precise
grasp of infinity anyway maybe we can
lay out enough axioms that capture the
elements of our own understanding of
infinity it won't articulate everything
but maybe it will articulate everything
in the human conception
of infinity so
again uh maybe we'll go back to steel
manning now i'm going to ask you to
steal man in part three of the book uh
the wonderful section uh you you end
part three by saying
very carefully uh you say we can't know
that we are not in a simulation
why did you phrase it like that and
what's the best argument against that in
other words against what would you say
to some what would you say on behalf of
somebody who says no we can know that we
are not in a simulation
yeah well if somebody says we can know
we're not in a simulation they want to
say how do they know what is the
evidence they'll presumably try and come
up with some evidence they say it's
conclusive evidence that we can't be in
a simulation the basic reason i think
that's impossible because it looks like
any evidence could itself be simulated
so if the evidence can be simulated then
we'll never know for sure in principle
we can have simulations
indistinguishable from unsimulated
reality so to defeat that someone's
going to need to
come up with something maybe you know
maybe who's to say like a penrose style
argument look human beings can do things
that no classical computer
could do i mean i'm dubious
about that but even if it were true i'd
think okay let's just move to quantum
computers or quantum gravity computers
and build our simulations
build our simulations like that
i mean maybe the biggest challenge is
consciousness could consciousness be
simulated and many people say
you're crazy if you think of simulation
could have consciousness but i haven't
thought about this a fair amount and i
don't see any bar
to uh consciousness and principle
being had by simulated creatures i would
at least say that we can't know
that consciousness can't be simulated so
maybe think of that that also justifies
this negative way of putting it i'm
lowering the bar for myself i don't want
to say we know we are in a simulation
because i think that's false i don't
think i know that for sure i think
there's some probability but we might
not be in a simulation so i want to say
but we might so the most important
thesis for me is we might be
and when you when you translate we might
be into like epistemic logic but not
logic of knowledge it just comes out as
not k not you can't know you're not in a
simulation but in
all their english yeah
exactly
so i appreciate that it's i think it's
always important to uh to describe these
things um
so i want to uh turn in the remaining uh
15 minutes if you can spare another 15
minutes there
okay great um so i'm going to ask you
first would you take the red
would i take the red pill what does the
red pill do for me
it lets me out of the matrix it gives me
access to all of reality i think i would
totally take the red pill because it's
going to enable me to it's like i grew
up in australia and australia was great
but then i discovered there was this
whole wide world out there and i wanted
to explore
the whole wide world if i grew up in the
matrix i think my view is the matrix is
real it's not like it it needn't be a
dystopia it depends on how it's run need
to be an illusion but if i discover that
i'm in reality and out there is reality
plus
if i get the opportunity to explore
reality plus then fantastic now i'm
going to want to be able to come back
to the matrix you know all my friend all
my family all my friends are going to be
in the uh they're going to be in the
matrix i don't want to lose touch with
them entirely and for me the matrix will
be part of reality but insofar as the
red pill represents knowledge
understanding exploration okay next uh
we have some questions from the audience
um so uh what do you think is the
ultimate and final machines that human
beings create this is from a man by the
name or a woman by the name of high
reality sensorium which i was going to
call my second child
so what's the ultimate machine that
humans homo sapiens could create
oh that's easy the ultimate machines
that hover samia's hope is saviors
creates is the first machine which is
smarter than homo sapiens
after that we will leave the creation
after that we will leave the creation to
the next question from poindexter if
david chalmers thinks the delayed choice
quantum erasure experiment results
support the simulation hypothesis
uh by observing error correction codes
in process where the prior state of
quantum entangled photon has changed to
match its entangled
counterpart
so does this cause the delayed choice
quantum eraser results which are not
fully definitively support i suppose um
do you believe that that has any bearing
say on the
support of the simulation hypothesis
yeah in general i'm dubious i haven't
really worked work carefully through
those uh those results in general um
there are various things in physics that
people have pointed to as potential
supports for simulation hypothesis
whether it's error correcting codes
possible glitches and uh and
approximations uh some people think that
you know the collapse of the wave that
the collapse of the wave function might
be potential support for uh
for the simulation hypothesis because it
shows like a a bit of rendering
efficiency okay well in vr people often
say don't render the world
until
you know for for the observer until you
need to
so some people say in quantum mechanics
where we're gonna yeah for efficiency
purposes we'll never collapse the wave
function until we need to but as far as
i can tell
the world with um
yeah the world with an uncollapsed wave
function is just as hard to simulate as
the one with the collapsed wave function
and yeah world with a whole lot of error
correcting codes that's going to add to
the audience the next question i'm
totally clear
about a
fellow philosopher
by the name of bernardo castro uh cash
truck i guess maybe um do you have any
uh thoughts or feelings on his work i'm
trying to eventually get him on the show
because he has the same initials as me
bk um so yeah emerging yeah what do you
think about his notion of analytic
idealism specific
yeah i know bernardo uh he came to a uh
to a conference i was involved in a few
years ago in shanghai actually
of all places on idealism on the thesis
that the universe
is all mind this is a view with a long
tradition in philosophy many of the
ancient indian philosophers
were idealists uh george barkley
uh in the uh
in the 17th 18th century was a
was an idealist in the 19th century
everyone was an idealist hegel
can't with the kind of ideas but it got
very unpopular for a long time but
lately it's had a bit of a comeback and
yeah in analytic philosophy in this
scientifically oriented philosophy a few
people are advocating the idea that
underneath the world might be a level of
uh of mine one way of getting there
actually is via the it from bit idea and
then you say what are the bits made of
we need a substrate some people say ah
consciousness
it from bit from consciousness
at the underlying level reality is the
interplay
of consciousness there are some people
the pan psychists
also put forward this idea anyway
bernardo
um i don't understand his view fully but
he certainly has the idea that
underneath physics is a level of mind
perhaps a single cosmic mind this
corresponds to what sometimes called
cosmo psychism it's like the whole
universe has a mind and we're just
aspects of that mind that i take this
view it's extremely speculative i think
it's got many big issues it needs to
address one big question is how does our
mind emerge from the cosmic mind or from
the bit minds no one's answered
that question yet but uh he i view him
as someone who's doing really
interesting
speculative physics james james
uh asked me is it true you told your
kids that if it is still not solved in
your lifetime you are to put quote still
hard on his tombstone true or false
yeah i'm hoping for i'm hoping that if
not i don't have kids but i'm hoping
that maybe uh
maybe that our ai successes will one day
solve the hard problem for us it's like
if it's too hard for it's too hard for
humans let's just program super
intelligent ais to create ever more
intelligent super intelligent ais
hopefully they'll be better you don't
have kids graduate students
and by the way what was douglas
hofstetter like as a graduate advisor
exactly
oh boy he's amazing he's full of you
know full of ideas
and passions and he was interested in
everything under the sun we'd have a
workshop one weekend on
on humor another one on creativity
another one on analogy another one on
sexist language and so on but he's also
passionate about me one thing you don't
quite get from his books in his books
he's such an enthusiast for so many
things
in the in the real world he's actually a
dis enthusiast for most things he hates
ninety percent of ai and eighty percent
of philosophy ninety percent of of
cognitive science and that comes out
also a little bit in in person but the
breadth
of his interest is amazing i love being
in his uh in his ai lab as a graduate
student so many smart
other graduate students around from
psychology and ai and following of
course
kind of at the center of the world
on the pulitzer prize
just quickly on the notion because i
can't resist like i asked you to you
know if you're ac dc to play back in
black i can't resist you asking you
about popper and and falsification as i
claim it's sort of a physicist version
of girdle's incompleteness theorem it's
kind of the best we have but it's not
quite as complete or good as as what
girdle did for mathematicians what do
you make of the uh of popperism is it
are we too in
in newer to the uh to the paparazzi as
leonard suskin calls them
i don't know popper kind of went out of
fashion in philosophy a while ago now
most people who think about the
philosophy of science and philosophy the
dominant tradition is bayesian we think
about this in terms of probabilities
higher probabilities lower probabilities
prior probabilities and their
interaction with evidence but this this
uh this total concentration on
falsification i mean yeah sure
falsification is important but in
general updating of probabilities by
evidence is the more
important thing
and by the way yes some people worry
about the simulation hypothesis that is
not falsifiable some versions of it
might be falsifiable imperfect
simulation hypothesis the perfect
simulation hypothesis maybe not
falsifiable in principle but that's just
to say okay the perfect simulation
hypothesis i'm happy to say is not
exactly a scientific hypothesis still a
philosophical hypothesis popper himself
put forward many philosophical
hypotheses that were in scientific
hypotheses so i think it can still be
meaningful we come to the end when i've
asked myself thrilling three existential
questions about the meaning of life your
past world line your future history your
gifts to the universe but to watch this
you're going to have to subscribe to my
youtube channel not you dave you're
going to watch it in real time because
you're going to participate in it but uh
you have to subscribe to my mailing list
briankeating.com and there i update and
i provide all the links to david's
wonderful work and his and his book of
course that you should buy i listened to
it and read it i think it's just one of
the i give your best to date and i can't
wait to see how successful it becomes so
if you want to hear dave answer the
thrilling three final questions you'll
have to subscribe to the channel and to
my mailing list briankeating.com i'll
send you the link so for now signing off
of this main portion of the episode into
the impossible with dave chalmers nyu
and author of reality plus a uh guide to
philosopher philosophies problems and
the ultimate answer to that to the uh
perhaps the most important questions of
the modern age dave thank you so much
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
so
[Music]